what is at a high level the game of
diplomacy
yeah so I talked a lot about two player
zero some games and what's interesting
about diplomacy is that it's very
different from these like adversarial uh
games like chess go poker even Starcraft
and DOTA diplomacy has a much bigger
Cooperative element to it it's a seven
player game it was actually created in
the 50s
um and it takes place uh before World
War one it's like a map of Europe with
seven Great Powers
um and they're all trying to form
alliances with each other there's a lot
of negotiation going on
um and so the whole focus of the game is
on
forming alliances with the other players
to take on the other players England
Germany Russia turkey Austria Hungary
Italy and France that's right yeah
so the way the game works is
on each turn you spend about you know
five to fifteen minutes talking to the
other players in privates and you make
all sorts of deals with them you say
like hey let's work together
um you know let's team up against this
other player because the only way that
you can make progress is by working with
somebody else against the others
um and then after that negotiation
period is done all the players
simultaneously submit their moves and
they're all executed at the same time
and so you can tell people like hey I'm
going to support you this turn
um but then you don't follow through
with it and they're only going to figure
that out once they see the moves being
read off how much of it is natural
language like written actual text how
much is like
um you're actually saying phrases that
are structured so there's different ways
to play the game you know you can play
it in person and in that case it's all
natural language
um free form communication there's no
constraints on the kinds of deals that
you can make the kinds of things that
you can discuss
um you can also play it online so you
can you know send along emails back and
forth
um you can play it like live online or
over voice chat but the the focus the
important thing to understand is that
this is unstructured communication you
can say whatever you want
um you can make any sorts of deals that
you want and everything is done
privately so it's not like you're all
around the board together having a
conversation you're grabbing somebody
going off into a corner and conspiring
behind everybody else's back about what
you're planning and uh there's no limit
in theory to the conversation you can
have directly with one person that's
right you can make all sorts of um you
can talk about anything you could say
like hey let's have a long-term alliance
against this guy you can say like hey
can you support me this turn and in
return I'll do this other thing for you
next turn or um you know yeah just you
can talk about like what you talked
about with somebody else and gossip
about like what they're planning
um the way that I would describe the
game is that it's kind of like a mix
between risk poker and the TV show
Survivor there's like this big element
of like trying to
um yeah there's a big social element and
the best way that I would describe the
game is that it's really a game about
people rather than the pieces
so risk because there is a map it's kind
of war game like
uh poker because there's a game theory
component that's very kind of strategic
so you could convert it into an
artificial intelligence problem and then
survive it because of the social
component that's a strong social
component I saw that somebody said
online that the internet version of the
game has this quality of that it's
easier to almost to do like role playing
as opposed to being yourself you can
actually like be the like really imagine
yourself as the leader of France or
Russia and so on like really pretend to
be that person it's actually fun to
really lean into being that that leader
yeah so some some players do go this
route where they just like kind of view
it as a strategy game but also a
role-playing game where they can like
act out like what would I be like if I
was you know a leader of France in 1900
a forfeit right away no I'm just kidding
um
and they sometimes use like the
old-timey language to like
um or how they imagine the elites would
talk at that time anyway so the what are
the different turns of the game like
what are the rounds yeah so on every
turn you got like a bunch of different
units that you start out with so you
start out um controlling like just a few
units and the object of the game is to
gain control of the majority of the map
if you able if you're able to do that
then you've won the game but like I said
the only way that you're able to do that
is by working with other players so on
every turn you can issue a move order so
for each of your units you can move them
to an adjacent territory
or you can keep them where they are or
you can support a move or a hold of a
different units so what are the
territories how how is the map divided
up it's kind of like Risk where the the
map is divided up into like 50 different
territories
um now you can enter a territory if
you're moving into that territory with
more supports than the person that's in
there or the person that's trying to
move in there so if you're moving in and
there's somebody already there
um then if neither of you have support
it's a one versus one and you'll bounce
back and another of you will make
progress if you have a unit that's
supporting that move into the territory
then it's a two versus one and you'll
kick them out and they'll have to
retreat somewhere what does support mean
support is like it's it's an action that
you can issue in the game so you can say
this unit you write down this unit is
supporting this other unit into this
territory are these units from opposing
forces they could be they could be and
this is this is where the interesting
aspect of the game comes in because you
can support your own units into
territory but you can also support other
people's units into territories and so
that's what the negotiations really
revolve around but you don't have to do
the thing you say you're going to do and
this yeah and so you can say I'm going
to support you but then backstab the
person yeah that's absolutely right and
that tension is core to the game that
tension is absolutely core to the game
the the fact that you can make all sorts
of promises but you have to reason about
the fact that like they might not trust
you if you say you're going to do
something or they might be lying to you
when they say they're going to support
you
so maybe just just to jump back what's
what's the history of the game in
general is it true that Henry Kissinger
loved the game and JFK and all those
I've heard like a bunch of different
people that or is that just one of those
things that the cool kids say they they
do but they don't actually play so the
game was created in the 50s yeah um and
from what I understand it was
um JFK's it was played in like the JFK
White House Henry Kissinger's favorite
game I don't know if it's true but um
that's definitely what I've heard it's
interesting that they went with World
War One
when it was created after World War II
so the story that I've heard for the
creation of the game is it was created
by
um somebody that had looked at the
history of the 20th century and they saw
World War one as a failure of diplomacy
so sure you know they saw the fact that
this war broke out as like the the
diplomats of all these countries like
really failed to prevent a war and he
wanted to create a game that would
basically teach people about diplomacy
um and it's really fascinating that like
in his ideal version of the game of
diplomacy nobody actually wins the game
because the whole point is that if
somebody is about to win then the other
players should be able to work together
to stop that person from winning and so
the ideal version of the game is just
one where nobody actually wins and you
know it kind of has a nice like
wholesome take-home message then that
you know war war is ultimately futile
and uh
and that optimal
that feudal optimal could be achieved
through great diplomacy yeah so uh is
there some asymmetry in in terms of
which is more powerful Russia versus
Germany versus
France and so on so I think the general
consensus is that France is the
strongest power in the game but the
beautiful thing about diplomacy is that
it's it's self-balancing right so it's
the fact that France has an inherent
Advantage from the beginning means that
the other players are less likely to
work with it I saw that Russia has four
units or four of something that the
others have three of something that's
true yeah so Russia starts off with four
units while all the other players start
with three but Russia is also in a much
more vulnerable position because they
have to like
um they have a lot more neighbors as
well got it larger territory more uh
yeah right more border to defend okay uh
what else is
what else is important to know about the
rules so there how many rounds are there
like is this iterative game is there is
it is it finite you just keep going
indefinitely usually the game lasts uh I
would say about
15 or 20 turns
um there's in theory No Limit it could
last longer but at some point I mean if
you're playing a house game with friends
at some point you just get tired and you
all agree like okay we're gonna end the
game here and call it a draw
um if you're playing online there's
usually like set limits on when the game
will actually end and what's the end
what's the termination condition like
this the there's one country have to
conquer everything else so if somebody
is able to actually gain control of a
majority of the map then then they've
won the game and that is a solo Victory
as it's called now that pretty rarely
happens especially with strong players
because like I said the game is designed
to incentivize the other players to put
a stop to that and all work together to
stop the superpower
um usually what ends up happening is
that you know all the players agree to a
draw and then the the score the the win
is divided among the the remaining
players
um there's a lot of different scoring
systems the one that we used in our
research
um basically
um gives a score relative to how much
control you have of the map so the more
that you control the higher you score
what's the history of using this game as
a benchmark for AI research do people
use it yeah so people have been working
on AI for diplomacy since about the 80s
um there was some really exciting
research back then but the approach that
was taken was very different from what
we see today I mean the research in the
80s was a very rule-based approach kind
of kind of a heuristic approach it was
very in line with the kind of research
that was being done in the 80s you know
basically trying to encode human
knowledge into the strategy of the AI
sure
um and you know it's understandable I
mean the game is so incredibly different
and so so much more complicated than the
kinds of games that people were working
on like chess and go uh and poker that
it was honestly even hard to like start
getting making any progress in in
diplomacy can you just formulate what is
the problem from an AI perspective and
why is it hard why is it a challenging
game to solve so there's a lot of
aspects in diplomacy that make it a huge
challenge first of all you have the
natural language components and I think
this really is what makes it
are really the most difficult
um game among like the major benchmarks
the fact that you have to it's not about
moving pieces on the board
your action space is basically all the
different sentences that you could
communicate to somebody else in this
game and um is there can we just like
Linger on that so
is part of it like the ambiguity in the
language
if it was like very strict
if you narrowed the set of possible
sentences you could do it would that
simplify the game significantly the the
real
difficulty is the breadth of things that
you can talk about
um you could have natural language in
other games and like Settlers of Catan
for example like you could have a
natural language Settlers of Catan AI
but the things that you're going to talk
about are basically like am I trading
you two sheep for a wood or three sheep
for wood
um whereas in a game like diplomacy the
breadth of conversations that you're
going to have are like you know am I
going to support you are you going to
support me in return which units are
going to do what uh what did this other
person say promise you uh they're lying
because they told this other person that
they're going to do this instead
um if you help me out this turn then in
the future I'll do these things that
will help you out
um the the depth and breadth of these
conversations is is really complicated
and it's all being done in natural
language
um now you could approach it and we
actually consider doing this like you
you know having a simplified language to
make this complexity uh smaller But
ultimately we thought the most impactful
way of doing this research would be to
address the natural language component
head-on and just try to go for the full
game up front just looking at sample
games and what the conversations look
like greetings England this should prove
to be a fun game since all the private
press is going to be made public at the
end
at the least it will be interesting to
see if the Press changes because of that
anyway good okay so there's like uh yeah
that's just kind of like the generic
readings at the beginning of the game I
think that the meat comes a little bit
later when you're starting to talk about
like specific strategy and stuff
I agree there are a lot of advantages to
the two of us keeping in touch in our
Nations makes strong natural allies in
the middle game so that kind of stuff uh
making friends making enemies yeah or
like if you look at the next line so the
person's saying like I've heard uh bits
about a Lepanto and an octopus opening
and basically telling Austria like hey
just a heads up you know I've heard
these whispers about like what might be
going on behind your back yeah but so
there's all kinds of complexities in
that
in the in the language of that right
like to interpret what that what the
heck that means it's hard for us humans
but for yeah it's even harder because
you have to understand like at every
level the the semantics of that right I
mean there's there's a complexity and
understanding when somebody is saying
this to me what does that mean and then
there's also the complexity of like
should I be telling this person this
like I've overheard these these Whispers
should I be telling this person that
like hey you might be getting attacked
by by this other power Okay so
what how we're supposed to think about
okay so that's the natural language how
do you even begin trying to solve this
game it seems like
this seems like the touring test on
steroids yeah and I mean there's there's
the natural language aspect and then
even besides the natural language aspect
you also have the The Cooperative
elements of the game and I think this is
actually
um something that I find really
interesting if you look at all the
previous game AI uh breakthroughs
they've all happened in these purely
Andrew serial games where you don't
actually need to understand how humans
play the game it's all just AI versus AI
right like you look at uh Checkers chess
go poker Starcraft Dota 2 like in some
of those cases they leveraged human data
but they never needed to they were
always just trying to have a scalable
algorithm that then they could throw a
lot of computational resources out a lot
of memory at and then eventually it
would converge to an approximation of a
Nash equilibrium this
perfect strategy that into two player
zero-sum game guarantees that they're
going to be able to not lose to any
opponents so you can't leverage
self-play to solve this game you you can
leverage self-play but it's no longer
sufficient to beat humans so how do you
integrate the human into the loop of
this so what you have to do is
incorporate human data
and to kind of give you some intuition
for why this is the case like imagine
you're playing a negotiation game like
like diplomacy
um but you're training completely from
scratch
without any human data the AI is not
going to suddenly like figure out how to
communicate in English it's going to
figure out some weird robot language
that only it will understand yeah and
then when you stick that in a game with
six other humans they're gonna think
this person's talking gibberish and
they're just going to Ally with each
other and team up against the bot
or not even team up against the ball but
just not work with the bot and so in
order to be able to play this game with
humans it has to understand the human
way of playing the game not this machine
way of playing the game yeah yeah that's
fascinating so right the the there's a
nuanced thing to understand because the
a chess playing program doesn't need to
play like a human to beat a human
exactly but here you have to play like a
human in order to beat them or at least
you have to understand how humans play
the game so that you can understand how
to work with them if they have certain
expectations about what does it mean to
be a good Ally what does it mean to have
like a reciprocal relationship where
we're working together you have to abide
by those conventions and if you don't
they're just going to work with somebody
else instead do you think of this as a
clean in some deep sense of the spirit
of the touring test that's formulated by
Alan Turing is is it in some sense this
is what the Turing test actually looks
like
so because of open-ended natural
language conversation seems like
very difficult to evaluate like here at
a high stakes where humans are trying to
win a game that seems like how you
actually
perform the Turing test I think it's
different from the touring test like the
way that the touring test is formulated
it's about trying to distinguish a human
from a machine and seeing Oh could the
machine uh successfully pass as a human
in this adversarial setting where the
eight where the player is trying to
figure out whether it's a machine or a
human whereas in diplomacy it's not
about trying to figure out whether this
player is a human or a machine it's
ultimately about whether I can work with
this player regardless of whether they
are a human or machine and can the
machine do that better than a human can
yeah I'm going to to think about that
but that just feels like
the implied requirement for that is for
the machine to be human-like
I think that's I think that's true that
if you're going to play in this human
game
you have to somehow adapt to the to the
human surroundings and the human
playstyle and to win you have to adapt
so you can't if you're the outsider
if you're not human-like I feel like
that's a losing strategy I think that's
I think that's correct yeah yeah so okay
uh
what what are the complexities here what
was your approach to it before I get to
that one thing I should explain like why
we decided to work on diplomacy so
basically what happened is in 2019
um I was wrapping up the work on six
player poker on pluribus and was trying
to think about what to work on next and
I had been seeing like all these other
breakthroughs happening in AI I mean
like 2019 you have Starcraft you have
Alpha star beating humans and Starcraft
you've got the Dota 2 stuff happening at
open AI you have GPT 2 or GPD 3 coming I
think it was gpd2 at the time and it
became clear that AI was progressing
really really rapidly
and people were throwing out these like
other games about you know what should
be the next challenge for for
multi-agent AI and I just felt like we
had to aim bigger
um
if you look at a game like chess or a
game like go they took decades for
researchers to to ultimately reach
superhuman performance at I mean like
chess took 40 Years of AI research go
took another 20 years
um
and
we we thought that diplomacy would be
this incredibly difficult challenge that
could easily take a decade to make an AI
that could play competently
um but we felt like that was that was a
goal worth aiming for
um
and so honestly I was kind of reluctant
to work on it at first because I thought
it was like too far out of the realm of
possibility but you know I was talking
to a co-worker of mine Adam Lear and he
was basically saying like eh why not aim
for it you know we'll learn some
interesting things along the way and
maybe it'll be possible
um and so so we decided to go for it and
I think I think it was the right choice
considering just how much progress there
there was in Ai and that that progress
has continued in the years since so
winning in diplomacy what does that
really look like it means talking to six
other players six other entities agents
and convincing
and convincing them of stuff that you
want them to be convinced of like what
what exactly I'm trying to get like to
deeply understand what the problem is
ultimately
the problem is it's simple to to
quantify right like you're going to play
this game with humans and you want your
score on average to be
um as high as possible you know if you
can say like I am winning more than any
any human alive
um then you're a champion diplomacy
player
um now ultimately we haven't we didn't
reach that we got to human level
performance we actually so we played
about 40 games with with real humans
online uh the bot came in second out of
all players that played five or more
games and um so not like number one but
way way higher than well what was the
expertise level are the beginners are
they intermediate players Advanced
players so you have a sense that's a
great question and so I think this kind
of goes into how do you measure the
performance in diplomacy and I would
argue that when you're measuring
performance in a game like this you
don't actually want to measure it in
games with all expert players uh it's
kind of like if you're developing a
self-driving car you don't want to
measure that car on the road with a
bunch of expert stunt drivers you want
to put it on a road of like an actual
American city and see is this car
crashing less often than an expert
driver would
so so that's the metric that we've used
we we're saying like we're going to
stick this game we're gonna stick this
bot in games with a wide variety of
skill levels and then are we doing
better than a strong or expert human
player would in the same situation
that's quite brilliant because I played
a lot of sports in my life like as a
tennis Judo whatever
and it's somehow almost easier to go
against experts almost always I don't I
think they're more predictable in the
quality of play the the space of
strategies you're operating under is
narrower against experts it's more fun
it's really frustrating to go against
beginners also because beginners talk
trash to you when they somehow do beat
you so that's a human thing that they
had isn't to be worried about that but
yeah the variance and strategies right
is greater especially with natural
language it's just all over the place
then true yeah and honestly when you
look at what makes a good human
diplomacy player
um obviously they're able to handle
themselves in games with other expert
humans but where they really shine is
when they're playing with these weak
players and they know how to take
advantage of the fact that they're a
weak player that they won't be able to
like pull off a stab as well or that
um they have certain Tendencies and they
can take them under their wing and
persuade them to do things that might
not even be in their interest
um the really good diplomacy players are
able to to take advantage of the fact
that there is that there are some weak
players in the game okay so if you have
to incorporate human play data how do
you do that how do you do that in order
to train an AI system to play diplomacy
yeah so that's that's really the Crux of
the problem how do we
um leverage the benefits of self-play
that have been so successful in all
these other previous games while keeping
the strategy as uh as human compatible
as possible
and so what we did is we first trained a
language model
um and then we made that language model
controllable on a set of in a set of
intents what we call intents which are
basically like an action that we want to
play and an action that we would like
the other player to play and so this
gives us a way to generate dialogue
that's not just trying to imitate the
human style
um whatever a human would say in the
situation but to actually give it a a an
intent a purpose in its communication we
can talk about a specific move or we can
make a specific request and the
determination of what that move is that
we're discussing comes from
um strategic strategic reasoning model
that uses reinforcement learning and
planning so the Computing the intents
for all the players
how's that done just so as a starting
point is that with reinforcement
learning or is that just optimal
determining what the optimal is for
intents It's a combination of
reinforcement learning and planning
um actually very similar to how you
approach how we approached poker and how
people approached like chess and go as
well we're using self-play and and
search to try to figure out what are
what is an optimal move for us and what
is a desirable move that we would like
this other player to play now the the
difference between the way that we
approached reinforcement learning and
search in this game versus those
previous games is that we have to keep
it human compatible we have to
understand how the other person is
likely to play rather than just assuming
that they're going to play like a
machine and how language gets them to
play
um in a way that maximize the chance of
following the intent you want them to
follow okay how do you do that how do
you how do you connect language to
intent so the way that RL and planning
is done is actually not using language
so we're coming up with this like plan
for the action uh that we're gonna play
and the other person's gonna play and
then we feed that action into the
dialogue model that will then send a
message according to those plans so the
language model there is mapping
action to to message to message
one word at a time
uh basically one message at a time so
we'll we'll feed into the dialogue model
like here are the actions that you
should be discussing here's the message
here is like the the
contents of the message that we would
like you to send and then it will
actually generate a message that
corresponds to that okay does this
actually work it works surprisingly well
okay how
oh man the the number of ways it
probably goes horribly I would have
imagined it goes horribly wrong
um so how the heck is it effective at
all I mean there are a lot of ways that
this could fail so for example I mean
you could have a situation where you're
you're basically like
we don't tell the the language model
like here are the pieces of our action
or the other person's action that you
should be communicating and so like
let's say you're about to attack
somebody you probably don't want to tell
them that you're going to attack them
but there's nothing in the language like
the language model is not very smart at
the end of the day so it doesn't really
have a way of knowing like well what
should I be talking about should I tell
this person I'm about to attack them or
not
um so we have to like develop a lot of
other techniques that that deal with
that
um like one of the things we do for
example is we try to calculate if I'm
going to send this message what would I
expect the other person to do in
response so if it's a message like hey
I'm going to attack you this turn
they're probably gonna you know attack
us or or defend against that attack and
so we have a way of recognizing like hey
sending this message is a negative
expected value action and we should not
send this message
so yes for particular kinds of messages
you have like an extra function that
does the uh estimates the value of that
message yeah so we have these kinds of
filters that like so it's a filter so
there's a there's a good and is that
filter in your network or is it rule
based that's that's a that's a neural
network so we're well it's a it's a
combination it's a neural network but
it's also using planning
um it's trying to compute like what is
the policy that the other players are
going to play Given that this message
um has been sent and then is that better
than not sending the message or I feel
like that's how my brain works too like
there's a language model that generates
random crap and then there's these other
neural Nets they're essentially filters
at least that's when I tweet
I'll usually my process of tweeting I'll
think of something and it's hilarious to
me and then about five seconds later the
filter Network comes in and says no no
that's not funny at all I mean there's
some something interesting to that kind
of process so you have a set of actions
that you you want you have an intent
that you want to achieve an intent that
you want your opponent to achieve then
you generate messages and then you
evaluated those messages will achieve
the the the
uh the goal you want yeah and we're
filtering for several things we're
filtering like is this a sensible
message you know so sometimes language
models will send will generate messages
that are just like totally nonsense
um and we try to filter those out we
also try to filter out messages that
that are basically lies
um so you know diplomacy has its
reputation as a game that's really about
um deception and lying but we try to
actually minimize the amount that the
bot would lie
um this was actually mostly or are you
no I'm just kidding okay
uh I mean like part of the reason for
this is that we actually found that
lying would make the bot perform worse
in the long run it would end up with a
lower score because once the bot lies
um people would never trust it again and
and trust is a huge aspect of the game
of diplomacy taking notes here because I
think this is applies to
to life lessons too I think it's a
really yeah really strong so like lying
is a dangerous thing to do like you you
want to avoid
obvious lying yeah I mean I think when
people play diplomacy for the first time
they approach it as a game of deception
and lying and and they
ultimately if you talk to top diplomacy
players what they'll tell you is that
diplomacy is a game about trust and
being able to build trust in an
environment that encourages people to
not trust anyone
so so that's the ultimate tension in
diplomacy how can this AI reason about
whether you are being honest in your
communication and how can the AI
persuade you that it is being honest
when it is telling you that hey I'm
actually going to support you this turn
is there some sense I don't know if you
step back and think that this process
well
indirectly help us study human
psychology
so like if trust is the ultimate goal
wouldn't that help us understand what
are the fundamental aspects of forming
trust between humans and between humans
and AI I mean that's a really really
important question that's much bigger
than the strategy games it's how can
that that's fundamental to the human
robot interaction problem how do we form
Trust
between intelligent entities
so one of the things I'm really excited
about with diplomacy
um there's never really been a good
domain to investigate these kinds of
questions yeah
um and diplomacy gives us a domain where
trust is really at the center of it
um and it's not just like you've hired a
bunch of mechanical turkers that you
know are being paid and trying to go
through the task as quickly as possible
you have these people that are really
invested in the outcome of the game and
they're really trying to do the best
that they can
um and so I'm really excited that we're
able to we actually like have put
together this we're open sourcing all of
our models we're open sourcing uh all of
the all the code and we're making the
data that we've used available to
researchers
um so that they can investigate these
kinds of questions so the data of the
different the human and the AI play of
diplomacy and the models that you use
for the generation of the messages and
the filtering yeah not not just even the
data of the AI playing with the humans
but all the training data that we that
we had that we used to train the AI to
understand how humans play the game
we're setting up a system where
researchers will be able to apply
um to be able to gain access to that
data and be be able to to use it in
their own research we should say what is
the name of the system
we're calling the bot Cicero Cicero and
what's the name like you're open
sourcing what's the name of the
repository and and the like the the
project is it also just called Cicero
the big project or are you still coming
up with a name the the data set comes
from this website weblomacy.net is this
site that's been online for like 20
years now and uh it's one of the main
sites that people use to play diplomacy
on it we've got like 50 000 games of
diplomacy with you know natural language
communication
um over 10 million messages so it's a
pretty massive data set that people can
use to um we're hoping that the the
academic Community the research
Community is able to use it for for all
sorts of interesting research questions
so do you from having studied this game
is this
a sufficiently rich problem space to
explore this kind of human AI
interaction yeah absolutely and I think
it's
I think it's maybe the best data set
that I can think of out there to to
investigate these kinds of questions of
negotiation trust
um persuasion I wouldn't say it's the
best data set in the world for human AI
interaction that's a very broad field
but I think that it's definitely up
there as like you know if you're really
interested in language models
interacting with humans in you know a
setting where their incentives are not
fully aligned this seems like an ideal
data set for investigating that
so you have
um you have a paper with some impressive
results and just an impressive paper
they're taking this problem on
what's the most exciting thing to you in
terms of the results from the the paper
well I think there's ideas or results
yeah I think there's a few aspects of
the results and um that I think are
really exciting so first of all the fact
that we were able to achieve such strong
performance
um I was
surprised by and pleasantly surprised by
um so we played 40 games of diplomacy
with real humans and the bot placed
second out of all players that have
played five or more games so it's about
80 players total
um 19 of whom played five or more games
and the bot was ranked second out of
those players
um and the bot was was really good in
two Dimensions one being able to
establish strong connections with the
other players on the board being able to
like persuade them to work with it
um being able to coordinate with them
about like how it's going to work with
them and then also the Raw
tactical and strategic aspects of the
game you know being able to understand
what the other players are likely to do
being able to model their behavior and
respond appropriately to that the bot
also really excelled at what are some
interesting things that the bot said
by the way are you allowed to swear in
the um okay are there rules to what
you're allowed to say or not in
diplomacy you can say whatever you want
I think the site will get very angry at
you if you start like threatening
somebody and if we actually like if
you're threaten somebody you're supposed
to do it politely yeah politely you know
keep it in character
um
we actually had a researcher watching
the bot 24 7 for well whenever we play a
game we had a bot watching it to make
sure that it wouldn't go off the rails
and start like threatening somebody or
something like that I would just love it
if the boss started like mocking
mocking everybody like some weird quirky
strategies would emerge have you seen
anything interesting that you huh that's
a weird that's a
that's a behavior either of the filter
or the or the language model that was
weird to you that was yeah they were
definitely like things that the bot
would would do that were not in line
with like how humans would approach the
game and that in a good way the humans
actually you know we we've talked to
some expert diplomacy players about
these results and their takeaways that
well maybe humans are approaching this
the wrong way and this is actually like
the right way to play the game
um so what's required to win like what
um what does it mean to mess up or to
exploit the sub-optimal behavior of a
player like um is there is there
optimally rational behavior and
irrational behavior that you need to
estimate that kind of stuff like what
what stands out to you like is there a
crack that you can exploit is there like
um a weakness that you can exploit in
the game that that everybody's looking
for
well I I think
you're asking kind of two questions
there so one like modeling the
irrationality and the sub-optimality of
humans
um
you can't in diplomacy you can't treat
all the other players like they're
machines and if you do that you're
you're going to end up playing really
poorly and so we actually ran this
experiment so we we trained a bot in a
two-player zero-sum version of diplomacy
um the same way that you might approach
a game like chess or poker and the bot
was superhuman it would crush any
competitor and then we took that same
training approach and we trained a bot
for the full Seven Player version of the
game through self-play without any human
data and we stuck it in a game with six
humans and it got destroyed even in the
version of the game where there's no
explicit natural language communication
it still got destroyed because it just
wouldn't be able to understand how the
other players were approaching the game
and be able to to work with that
um can you just link on that meeting
like there's an individual there's an
individual personality each player and
then you're supposed to remember that
but what do you mean it's not able to
understand uh the players well it would
for example expect the human to support
it in a certain way when the human men
would simply like think like no I'm not
supposed to support you here
um it's kind of like you know if you
develop a self-driving car and it's
trained completely from scratch with
other self-driving cars it might learn
to drive on the left side of the road
that's a totally reasonable thing to do
if you're with these other self-driving
cars that are also driving on the left
side of the road but if you put it in an
American city it's gonna crash but I
guess the intuition I'm trying to build
up is why does it then crush a human
play on heads up
this is multiple this is an aspect of
two player zero song versus games that
involve cooperation so in a two-player
zero-sum game
um you can do self-play from scratch and
you will arrive at the Nash equilibrium
where you don't have to worry about the
other player
playing in a very human sub-optimal
style that's just going to be that the
only way that deviating from an ash
equilibrium
would would change things is if it
helped you so I what's the dynamic of
cooperation that's effective in
diplomacy
do you always have to to have one friend
in the game you always want to maximize
your friends and minimize your enemies
got it and
boy in the the lying comes into play
there
so the more friends you have the better
yeah I mean I guess you have to attack
somebody or else you're not going to
make progress right so that's the
tension but man this is too real this is
too real to this is too too close to
geopolitics of actual military conflict
in the world okay
uh that's fascinating so that
cooperation element is what makes the
game really really hard yeah and to give
you an example of of how this
sub-optimality and irrationality comes
into play there's a really common
situation in the game of diplomacy
um that where one player starts to win
and they're like at the point where
they're controlling about half the map
yeah um and the remaining players who
have all been fighting each other the
whole game all have to like work
together now to stop this other player
from winning or else everybody's gonna
lose
um and it's kind of like you know Game
of Thrones like I don't know if you've
seen the show like you know you got the
the others coming from the north and
like all the people have to start work
out their differences and stop them from
from taking over
um
and the bot will do this like the bot
will work with the other players to stop
the superpower from winning but if it
doesn't really if it's trained from
scratch or it doesn't really have a good
grounding in how humans approach it it
will also at the same time attack the
other players with its extra units so
all the units that are not necessary to
stop the superpower from winning it will
use those to grab as many centers as
possible from the other players and
in totally rational play the other
players should just live with that you
know they have to understand like hey a
score of one is better than a score of
zero so um so okay he's grabbed my
centers but I I'll just deal with it
but humans don't act that way right the
human gets really angry at the bot and
ends up throwing the game because you
know I'm gonna screw you over because
you did something that's not fair to me
got it and are you supposed to model
that is the boss supposed to model that
kind of human frustration yeah exactly
and so that is something that seems
almost impossible to model purely from
scratch without any human data it's a
very cultural thing yeah um and so you
need
human data to be able to understand that
hey that's how humans behave and you
have to work around that it might be
suboptimal it might be irrational but
but that's an aspect of humanity that
you have to have you have to deal with
so how difficult is it to train on human
data given that human data is very
limited versus what us a purely
self-play mechanism can generate that's
actually one of the major challenges
that we faced in the research that we
had a good amount of human data we had
about 50 000 games what we try to do is
leverage as much self-play as possible
while still leveraging the human data so
what we do is we do self-play very
similar to how it's been done in poker
and go but we try to regularize the
self-play towards the human data
basically the way to think about it is
um we penalize the bot for choosing
actions that are very unlikely under how
under the human data set
and how do you know is there is some
kind of function that says this is
human-like enough yeah so we we train a
bot through supervised learning to model
the human play as much as possible so we
basically like train a neural net
um on those 50 000 games and that gives
us an approximate that gives us a policy
that resembles to some extent how humans
actually play the game now this isn't a
perfect model of human play because we
don't have unlimited data we don't have
unlimited neural net capacity
um but it gives us some approximation uh
is there some data on the internet
that's useful besides just diplomacy so
on the language side of things is there
some can you go to like Reddit
and
um so sort of background model
formulation that that's useful for the
game of diplomacy yeah absolutely and so
for the language model which
um it's kind of like a separate question
you know we didn't use the language
model during self-play training but we
pre-trained the language model on you
know tons of internet data as much as
possible and then we fine-tuned it
specifically on the diplomacy games so
we are able to like Leverage The Wider
data set in order to fill in
some of the gaps in like how
communication happens more broadly
besides just like specifically in these
diplomacy games Okay cool so what what's
some what are some interesting things
that came to life from this from this
work uh to you like what are some
insights
about
um
about games with where natural language
is involved and cooperation deep
cooperation is involved well I think
there's a few insights um so first of
all
the fact that you can't rely purely or
even largely on self-play that you
really have to have an understanding of
how humans approach the game
um I think that that's one of the major
conclusions that I'm drawing from this
work
um and that is I think applicable more
broadly to a lot of different games so
we've actually already taken the
approaches that we've used in diplomacy
and tried them on uh Cooperative card
game called Hanabi and we've had a lot
of success in that game as well
um on the language side
I think the fact that we were able to
control the language model through this
intense approach was very effective
um and it allowed us instead of just
imitating how humans would communicate
we're able to go beyond that and able to
feed into it superhuman strategies that
it can then um you know generate
messages corresponding to
is there something you could say about
detecting whether a person or AI is
lying or not
the bot doesn't explicitly try to
calculate whether somebody is lying or
not but what it will do is try to
predict what actions they're going to
take given the communications given the
messages that they've sent to us so
given our conversation what do I think
you're going to do and implicitly there
is a calculation about whether you're
lying to me in that
you know if if you're based on your
messages if I think you're going to
attack me this turn
um even though your messages say that
you're not then you know essentially the
bot is predicting that you're lying but
it doesn't view it as as lying the same
way that we would view it as lying but
you could probably reformulate with all
the same data and make a classifier
lying or not
yeah I think I think you could do that
um that was not something that we were
focused on but I think that it is
possible that you know if you came up
with some measurements of like what does
it mean to tell a lie because there's a
spectrum right like if you're
withholding some information is that a
lie
um if you're mostly telling the truth
but you forgot to mention this like one
action out of like 10 is that a lie
um it's hard to draw the line but you
know if you're willing to do that and
then you could possibly use it to uh
dude this feels like an argument inside
a relationship now what constitutes a
lie
um depends what you mean by the
definition of the word is okay
um
still it's fascinating because trust and
lying is all intermixed into this and
it's language models that are becoming
more and more sophisticated it's just a
fascinating space to explore
um
what do you see as the future of this
work
um that is inspired by the Breakthrough
performance that you're getting here
with diplomacy
um
I think there's a few different
directions to take this work
um
I I think really what it's showing us is
the potential that language models have
I mean I think a lot of people didn't
think that this kind of result was
possible even today despite all the
progress that's been made in language
models and so it shows us how we can
Leverage The Power of things like
self-play on top of language models to
get
um increasingly better performance and
the ceiling is really
much higher than what we have right now
is this transferable somehow to to chat
Bots
for the more General task of dialogue
so because there is a kind of
negotiation here a dance between
entities that are trying to cooperate
and at the same time a little bit
adversarial which I think Maps somewhat
to the general
you know the entire process of Reddit or
like internet communication you're
cooperating you're adversarial you're
having debates you're having uh
camaraderie all that kind of stuff
I think one of the things that's really
useful about diplomacy is that we have a
well-defined value function there is a
well-defined score that the bot is
trying to optimize and and in a in a
setting like a general chat bot setting
it needs it would need that kind of
um objective in order to fully leverage
the techniques that we've developed
what about like what we talked about
earlier with NPCs inside video games
like how can it be used to create
for Elder Scrolls 6 more compelling um
NPCs
that you could talk to instead of
instead of committing all kinds of
violence with a sword and fighting
dragons just sitting in a Tavern and
drink all day and talk to the chatbot
the way that we've approached Ai and
diplomacy is you condition the language
on an intent now that intent and
diplomacy is an is an action but it
doesn't have to be and you can imagine
you know you could have NPCs in video
games or the metaverse or whatever where
there's some intent or there's some
objective that they're trying to
maximize and you can specify what that
is
um and and then the language can
correspond to that intent now I'm not
saying that this is you know happening
imminently but I'm saying that this is
like a future application potentially of
this direction of research so what's the
more General formulation of this making
self-play be able to scale the way
self-play does and still maintain
human-like Behavior
the way that we've approached self-play
in diplomacy is like
we're we're trying to
come up with good intents to condition
the language model on and the space of
intents is actions that can be played in
the game now there is like the potential
to have a broader set of intents things
like you know long-term cooperation or
long-term uh objectives or you know
gossip about what another player was
saying
um these are things that we're currently
not conditioning the language model on
and so it's not able to we're not able
to control it to say like oh you should
be talking about this thing right now
but it's quite possible that you could
expand the scope of intents to be able
to allow it to talk about those things
now in the process of doing that the
self-play would become much more
complicated
um and so that is a potential for for
future work okay the increase in the
number of intents I still am not quite
clear
how you keep the self-play
integrated into the human world yeah I'm
a little bit loose on the uh uh on
understanding how you do that so we
train a neural Nets to
um imitate the human data as closely as
possible and that's what we call the
anchor policy and now when we're doing
self-play
that the problem with the anchor policy
is that it's not a perfect approximation
of how humans actually play because we
don't have infinite data because we
don't have unlimited neural network
capacity it's actually a relatively
sub-optimal approximation of how humans
actually play and we can improve that
approximation by adding planning and RL
and so what we do is we get a better
approximation a better model of human
play by
during the self-play process we say you
can deviate from this human anchor
policy if there is an action that has
you know particularly High expected
value but
it would have to be a really high
expected value in order to to deviate
from from this human-like policy so you
basically say try to maximize your
expected value while at the same time
stay as close as possible to the human
policy and there is a parameter that
controls those the the relative
weighting of those Computing objectives
so the question I have
is how sophisticated can the anchor
policy get
to have a policy that approximates human
behavior right yeah so as you increase
the number of intents as you generalize
the the space in which this is
applicable
and given that the human data is limited
try to anticipate a policy that works
for in a much larger number of cases
like how how difficult is the process of
forming a damn good anchor policy
well it really comes down to how much
human data you have so it's all about
scale in the human data I think the more
human data you have the better and I
think that that's going to be the major
bottleneck in in scaling to to more
complicated
um domains but that said
you know there might be the potential
just like in the language model where we
leveraged you know tons of data on the
internet and then specialized it for
diplomacy
um there is the future potential that
you can leverage huge amounts of data
across the board and then specialize it
in the data set that you have for
diplomacy and in that way you're
essentially augmenting the amount of
data that you have